[Musique]
bonsoir lundi 2 mars bienvenue pour
cette nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 60,18 voici les titres de
ce journal le premier tour des élections
municipales c'est dans moins de deux
semaines focus chaque jour sur la
campagne dans les yvelines dans cette
édition présentation des candidats à
saint-cyr-l'ecole une quatrième liste se
déclare à maurepas et nous recevons
nicolas hué en lice aux clayes-sous-bois
une première dans les yvelines le
domaine de madame elisabeth à versailles
accueillait le premier forum économique
afrique français cartier
objectif aider les entrepreneurs issus
de la diaspora africaine à investir dans
leur pays de leurs origines
et puis nous parlerons d'habiter mieux
un programme mené par le département des
yvelines avec l'anah pour aider les
ménages modestes à réaliser des travaux
de rénovation énergétique est la
collectivité ambitionne d'en accompagner
6000 sur les cinq prochaines années
cette information pour débuter ce
journal la direction d'airbus des feuns
n space annonce la suppression de plus
de 400 postes en france sur le site
d'elancourt 92 postes sont concernés 36
le sont également pour les filiales du
groupe toujours est elle en cours et
aussi à toulouse pas de licenciements
secs mais un plan de départs volontaires
qui va s'échelonner entre juillet 2020
et fin 2021 est les représentants
syndicaux de la division d'airbus
spécialisé dans les équipements
militaires et spatiaux ont exprimé leur
inquiétude quant aux possibles manque
d'effectif en cas de reprise intensive
du marché de l'espace
[Musique]
le premier tour des élections
municipales se rapproche du mans 13
avant le dimanche 15 mars et depuis
jeudi dernier elle nous connaissons les
candidats définitif pour le scrutin 280
ulis sont déclarés en tout dans les
yvelines
c'est une certitude il n'y aura qu'un
seul tour dans au moins 74 communes du
département qui compte une ou deux
listes avec neuf candidatures
candidature c'est au vésinet qu'il ya le
plus de listes inscrites sur le
territoire données complètes à retrouver
sur le site de la préfecture des
yvelines à maurepas il y aura finalement
quatre listes pour les élections
municipales
erwan le gall le premier adjoint de
grégory gary astier se lance à son tour
dans la campagne
annonce faite en fin de semaine dernière
mélanie poquet et michael et demi
d'euros le premier adjoint au maire à
têtes de listes pour ce scrutin
municipal à one de galles a choisi de
présenter sa propre équipe au mort passe
bien une candidature où l'on retrouve
d'anciens membres de la majorité
municipale sylvestre données est lui
aussi adjoint au maire nathalie
bellegarde et à gâteaux des il y a dans
la vie des séparations des mariages
forcés il y à un certain nombre de
choses qui peuvent se passer
nous avons décidé avec mort pas
autrement et l'ensemble de l'équipe de
porter un vrai projet évidemment qu'il
ya une réflexion sur la tête de liste
une réflexion sur le programme une liste
composée d'étudiants des chefs
d'entreprise de retraités et de
financiers au programme de cette équipe
les entreprises la sécurité la
démocratie participative et
l'environnement faire des propositions
pour la commune avec des coûts
financiers maîtrisé voilà ça c'est un
axe important n'est pas question d'aller
partir de partir sur des projets
démesurés pour que les impôts et la
fiscalité des norvégiens s'enflamme nous
on voudrait faire un bilan carbone déjà
de la commune
enfin en tout cas des actions communales
de la ville de savoir si
on est bien on n'est pas bien avec nos
véhicules avec la mobilité des agents
avec notre structure
la structure municipale qui est la
mairie quatre listes seront donc
présents dans les bureaux de vote le 15
mars face à erwan le gall le maire
sortant grégory gare et astier et les
conseillers municipaux d'opposition
ismaila vannes et michel chapa et une
petite précision ce sont bien 680 eu
listes qui seront candidates dans les
yvelines j'ai annoncé tout à l'heure 288
le chiffre de 688 qui s'affiche
actuellement sur votre écran est bien le
bon à oakley sous bois par deux ils
seront cinq candidats parmi eux nicolas
eu bon soir vous êtes élue d'opposition
depuis 15 ans dans la commune pour la
première fois vous êtes candidat tête de
liste pour ce scrutin des municipales
votre liste un autre projet pour les
clayes-sous-bois une candidature qui est
soutenu notamment par plusieurs partis
de gauche génération auquel vous
appartenez mais aussi à la france
insoumise le ps le parti communiste ou
encore europe ecologie les verts
comment se déroule votre campagne est ce
que de nouveaux rendez vous sont prévus
dans les dernières semaines qui
précèdent le scrutin tout à fait alors
cette campagne se passe très très bien
comme nous l'avons commencé nous la
poursuivons c'est à dire que nous allons
à la rencontre des chrétiens en divers
stands et porte à porte des réunions
publiques comme nous avons précisément
commencé cette campagne en créant
justement le projet avec eux nous
continuons et nous continuons à élaborer
avec eux et donc nous avons des réunions
publiques qui sont prévues cette semaine
le 3 mars et le 5 mars une dans chaque
quartier de la ville
et puis la dernière le 9 mars quelques
jours avant le premier tour
pour ces derniers jours avant le premier
tour des municipales alors samedi
dernier vous avez organisé une opération
à la recherche et des pistes cyclables
oakley ça ça fait partie des
propositions phares vos portes et
développer un réseau cyclable aux
clayes-sous-bois tout à fait d'un point
de vue général évidemment la question
écologique et environnemental et un de
nos points et un de nos axes principal
est un de nos points forts
et nous avons justement essayer de
diagnostiquer sur l'ensemble de la
commune
l'ensemble des réseaux cyclables qui
serait à mettre en oeuvre et à
développer des réseaux partagés ou des
roseaux en propre et notamment en lien
avec nos communes voisines ville premier
plaisir parce que nous sommes réellement
un briquet ces trois communes les unes
dans les autres et nous percée
importante de diagnostic diagnostiqué
par nos la manière de relier ces trois
villes pour nous rendre vers les centres
commerciaux ou les sites administratifs
de ces trois villes
parce que ce genre de projet il faut le
penser à un niveau intercommunal fois le
définir avec les autres communes ça ça
alors déjà il faut manier évidemment
correctement la ville c'est à dire que
les trois quartiers que comporte notre
ville quartiers nord quartier ouest et
quartier centre soit correctement reliés
les uns aux autres et puis il me semble
bien entendu que lorsque nous avons des
communes aussi limitrophes que plaisir
et villepreux
il faut penser évidemment à pouvoir
mailler ses réseaux avec ces communes
pour que les habitants d'une commune
puisse se développer de manière puis
cependant se déplacer d'une manière
tranquille d'une voix et d'une
commune à l'autre et ce de manière
sécurisée il vous l'avez dire ça fait
partie bien sûr de vos propositions en
matière de transition écologique et on
peut le dire l'un des thèmes phares de
cette campagne des municipales
que peut faire le maire justement sur
cette thématique de la transition
écologique sur la transition écologique
il y a beaucoup de choses à mettre en
oeuvre et notamment par exemple une d un
des points qui nous nous tient à coeur
sur sur les clayes-sous-bois c'est la
maîtrise de notre urbanisme et la
maîtrise et le respect de notre
environnement et de nos espaces verts je
prends pour exemple le centre le parc
des bruyères qui est aujourd'hui en gros
sujet au sein de la ville que la
majorité sortante aujourd'hui divisée en
deux listes
madame frémont et mais ce qui gêne
souhaite bâtir de nouveaux pour du
logement et du logement d'un certain
niveau nous nous souhaitons que ces sept
mille mètres carrés en plein coeur de
ville de l'espace de verdoyant et des
espaces de verdure puisse rester ainsi
parce que c'est justement un projet qui
est totalement anachronique
on se rend compte que dans de nombreuses
communes aujourd'hui on fait le choix
inverse de revégétaliser nos espaces or
là on nous demanderait de re bétonner un
espace qui aujourd'hui déjà verdoyant
c'est totalement contre contre nature et
contreproductif et nous nous souhaitons
évidemment préserver ce centre est ce
parc en y installant un projet
intergénérationnel qui allie les
personnes âgées et évidemment les plus
jeunes d'entre nous autre point qui est
ressorti de votre co construction du
programme avec les clés sien c'est le
thème de la sécurité qui est un thème
qui intéresse en tout cas qui peut être
inquiète aussi les clés siens tout à
fait aujourd'hui les listes
là
majorité sortante essentiellement
focalisé son attention sur la question
de la vidéosurveillance c'est c'est une
chose qui s'est développé je pense que
nous avons maintenant sur la ville un
réseau assez mallet de caméras de
vidéosurveillance mais pour moi rien ne
remplace la présence humaine et c'est
pour ça que nous allons nous proposer
que nous proposons à renforcer justement
les équipes de médiation sociale
nous partons nous sur un triptyque qui
est simple c'est prévenir agir et
sanctionner prévenir et agir c'est
évidemment avec une équipe de médiateur
social une équipe de correspondants nuit
puisque nous savons aussi que de
nombreuses incivilités se produisent à
partir de 20h 21h jusqu'à une heure du
matin et qu'il faut qu'il y ait un lien
là entre les habitants et les services
de police qui peut être justement prise
en charge par la puissance publique à
travers les correspondants de nuit et le
troisième axe sur la sanction doublettes
sur l'action est évidemment pour nous le
renforcement des forces de police sur le
secteur notamment avec la création d'une
police de sécurité du quotidien qui est
d'ailleurs un projet qui a été proposé
par le ministère de l'intérieur il ya
déjà deux ans et nous souhaitons nous
nous y inclure parce qu il nous paraît
important d'avoir les trois maillons de
cette chaîne
mis bout à bout pour que enfin on puisse
vivre de manière sécurisée en tout cas
sereine aux clayes-sous-bois un dernier
mot très rapide sur un autre thème la
démocratie participative aussi qui
revient souvent dans cette campagne des
municipales
est ce que si vous êtes élu maire vous
allez aller vers davantage de démocratie
participative est ce que c'est votre
souhait donc les sous-bois oui je pense
que c'est nécessaire
en 19 ans les christian n'ont jamais été
réellement consulter
sur les grands projets d'envergure de la
commune je parlais tout à l'heure du
centre de loisirs des bruyères je parle
maintenant je peux parler aussi
maintenant deux du marché de la
restructuration du marché
nous voyons aujourd'hui la
restructuration du pôle gare
dans lequel les chrétiens avaient des
demandes et avait proposé des de
nombreuses choses qui n'ont pas été
prises en compte par la maire sortante
et part donc son équipe qui se
représentent et nous nous souhaitons
aujourd'hui qu'il y ait une vraie action
de la part des chrétiens une
collaboration une co élaboration avec
nous de l'ensemble des dispositifs que
nous mettrons en place notamment à
travers les dispositifs de votation
citoyenne qui permettront aux clés siens
de se prononcer sur des grands projets
d'envergure de la commune voilà pour vos
thématiques nicolas et merci d'être
passé en plateau je rappelle que vous
êtes la tête de liste d'un autre projet
pour les clayes-sous-bois je précise que
c'est votre première candidature en tant
que tête de liste aux clayes sous bois
et son candidat également dans la
commune
l adjointe anne claire vraiment le
premier adjoint philippe dit guen
olivier august 1 pour lutte ouvrière et
stéphanie jamin qui convient une
candidature citoyenne et du côté de
montigny le bretonneux l'ancien
directeur de cabinet de la majorité
sortante a présenté sa liste aux
habitants en fin de semaine dernière une
candidature basée notamment sur la
transition écologique marylène iapichino
l'équipe de montigny ensemble présenter
aux habitants les 39 nom comporte autant
d'anciens de la majorité municipale
venus apporter leur expérience que de
nouveaux pour un regard neuf aujourd'hui
je présente une équipe à la population
qui a une moyenne d'âge de 43 ans
et dans cette équipe j'ai fait rentrer
des gens qui étaient tous des personnes
investies soit dans le milieu associatif
soit dans les conseils de quartier
les rôles sont distribués en fonction
des appétences et compétences de chacun
je vais déjà essayer d'être au plus près
des parents d'élèves et également des
enseignants déjà dans un premier temps
de faire un tour d'horizon des questions
qui peuvent se poser des problèmes qui
se posent pour essayer de bien
diagnostiqué le sujet et naturellement
aussi les jo qui va être une grande fête
et qu'il faut qu'on réussisse au mieux
laurent merker a aussi présenté
certaines propositions de son programme
réhabilitation du centre-ville sécurité
le contact avec les habitants et une
fiscalité mesurée maîtrisée seront les
points importants avec aussi
l'environnement pour lequel il propose
la création d'une délégation mêlant
fiscalité et transition écologique
je pense qu'aujourd'hui si on veut pas
être dans le discours mais dans la mise
en oeuvre de d'un vrai projet de
transition écologique
le nerf de la guerre c'est l'argent et
donc si on veut avoir une vraie
transformation des services de la ville
il faut situer la transition écologique
au niveau de la gestion des finances
puisque c'est la finance qui arbitre
tout ce qui va se jouer dans les autres
services
il équipe montigny ensemble va désormais
présenter son programme complet aux
habitants chaque week end et poursuivre
les réunions d'appartement déjà engagé
deux autres listes sont engagés dans la
commune à saint-cyr-l'ecole deux
candidates ont déposé leurs listes pour
les élections municipales sonia broc
maire sortant et fasse elle l ai dit
lydie du long pont présentation avec
mathilde domini à saint-cyr-l'ecole
commune de 18 mille cinq cents habitants
de candidats de se pose
sonia bros tête de liste de saint cyr au
coeur 2020 anciennement première
surveillante dans l'administration
pénitentiaire elle s'engage en politique
en 2008 sur la campagne électorale avec
le souhait de s'investir dans la ville
elle succède au mandat de bernard de
bain et devient maire en 2019
le programme il est à l'image de
l'équipe c'est à dire est une
il regroupe les besoins les envies de
chaque quartier de saint cyr et on va y
trouver à l'intérieur l'envi qu'on peut
monter voir monter aujourd'hui des saint
cyriens de participer à la vie
municipale ce qui n'était pas forcément
toujours le cas et j'en suis ravi ça
veut peut-être dire qu'on aura plus
d'électeurs plus de participation à
l'élection municipale en 2020 lydie du
long pot tête de liste de
saint-cyr-l'ecole en commun actuellement
animatrice de communauté
elle s'est lancée dans le mouvement
local citoyen et participatif investi
dans la vie associative locale
elle est devenue éducatrice à
l'environnement avant de devenir tête de
liste
si je me suis investi dans ce mouvement
c'est parce que je pense que il est très
important d'agir maintenant et qu'on ne
peut pas se permettre d'attendre encore
six ans pour être vraiment au contact
proche des habitants et savoir ce qui
les intéresse et ce qu'ils ont envie de
faire pour l'heure pour leur ville et
d'ailleurs ce soir tv 78 radio
sensations yvin vous propose un débat
entre les deux candidates 200 cyr
l'école émission à retrouver dès 20h sur
notre chaîne ou sur la fréquence 98 104
fm pour nos confrères de sensations
yvelines
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité ce
financement accordé par le crous et
l'université à versailles saint quentin
l'association au poème 14700 euros pour
aider à un projet celui de distribuer à
des protections menstruel gratuitement
pour les étudiantes de l'ue vs qu elle
reçoit trois personnes pour en parler
nous avons charlotte laurent bonsoir
baptiste andré bonsoir et de l'autre
côté nous avons maintenant viltard
bonsoir alors vous êtes tous les trois
étudiants en médecine troisième année de
médecine à lui fait est-ce qu membres de
l'association poèmes et vous avez porté
ce projet juste pour revenir sur les
origines comment vous est venue l'idée
de voile a proposé ces distributions
gratuites de protection menstruel qui le
démarrer peut-être charlotte alors en
fait dès qu'on a intégré l'association
là se battre pour la précarité menstruel
a été une de nos idées on voulait
proposer des protections danse truelle
aux étudiantes déjà par le biais de
commandes groupées pour essayer de
réduire les frais
mais c'était toujours trop cher parce
que savoir que c'est un budget c'est à
peu près 30 ou 40 euros par personne
pour s'équiper en réutilisables je parle
serviette réutilisables que cup
menstruel donc on s'est dit on a envie
de trouver des financements pour aider
les personnes construit et notamment les
plus précaires et on a commencé par
faire un sondage avec des questions
ciblées pour avoir des chiffres forme
ensui trouver des financements on a
appris quelques chiffres du sondage très
bien alors quelles sont les conclusions
du coût de ce sondage que vous avez mené
les premières conclusions hâtives
on a déjà il est encore ouvert en ce
sondage on précise exactement 10 il ya
un qr code qu'on a partagé sur plein
d'affichés qu'on va mettre dans
le plus d'universités possible donc là
on a reçu 465 réponse dans le sondage
et il ya quatre-vingts pour cent des
étudiantes qui ont répondu au sondage
qui utilisent des serviettes jetables
aujourd'hui et 52% des tampons jetables
il ya quand même 15,7 pour cent qui
utilisent des cups et césure gül 2 %
utilisent des serviettes l'avap donc
notre objectif c'est de proposer aussi
donc des serviettes lavables pour que
certaines étudiantes qui le veulent
puissent passer le cap et utiliser un
moyen de protection plus écologique est
aussi plus rentable ça parce qu'au bout
de cinq mois ça devient très vite
rentable puis le moyen et sera
biologique c'est ça c'était aussi votre
objectif c'est répondre aux besoins des
étudiantes qui ont des soucis financiers
mais aussi celles qui ont besoin de
passer le cap pour une conscience
écologique
d'ailleurs si on regarde quelques
chiffres aussi 20% des sondés disent
avoir déjà bricoler une protection dans
ce cruel 6,6 pour cent avouent également
avoir dû faire le choix certes un mois
entre s'acheter une protection menstruel
ou s'acheter des produits de première
nécessité charlotte le disais tout à
l'heure m'annoncer sont des protections
qui coûtent cher c'est un budget chaque
mois mais c'est vraiment un budget et
nous on a trouvé des plus revendeur mon
pour les hyper me permettent aux
étudiants d'avoir des moins chères
s'avoue très cher fins et 15 euros la
savait terre utilisable il en faut au
moins six pour pouvoir durer pendant le
cycle donc c'est vraiment très compris
c'est un investissement est légèrement
les étions pas l'argent enfin ils
peuvent pas se permettre de payer 100
euros 1 mois même si c'est très vite
rentabilisé peuvent parce que paris est
donc vous êtes investis dans ce projet
pour obtenir je le rappelle c'est 14
1700 euros vous avez dû répondre à un
appel à projets a expliqué nous un petit
peu comment ça s'est déroulé du coup
pour obtenir ce financement alors suite
et le sondage publié sur le site de l'ue
est exclu et du campus qui ont été
reliés il ya le vice président étudiant
de véhicules qui nous a contactés qui
nous a dit que le projet l'intéressait
et qu'il y avait enfin on avait un appel
à projets à répondre dans les trois
jours
donc on a rempli le dossier on a fait
des dons à chercher des demandes de
financement et on a rempli dossier on a
présenté à une commission
ils ont trouvé le projet vraiment génial
escales qui nous ont donné une certaine
somme de 14 mille 700 euros sur les
cinquante six mille je crois qu'ils
étaient demandés à la base ça veut dire
vous allez continuer à chercher d'autres
financements aussi
et d'ailleurs on profite de ce moment de
visibilité pour faire pour vous appeler
s'il ya des financeurs qui sont
intéressés des mairies des financeurs
publics comme privés et également des
dons car suite à l'article dans la
gazette de saint quentin en yvelines on
a un monsieur qui nous a contacté pour
me donner une machine à coudre
donc on est allé récupérer c'était un
super moment des changes
et voilà si vous avez des machines à
coudre qui dorment dans le placard nous
on pourra les utiliser pour coudre avoir
confectionné ensuite ces protections en
suède le site de l'association poèmes
qui s'affiche pour prendre contact avec
vous 4500 étudiants tous qui vont
pouvoir profiter de cette aide
où et quand vont se dérouler ces
distributions à ce qu'elles sont déjà
programmées on fera les distributions
sur les différents campus de duvet
excuse mais on attend vraiment d'obtenir
les financements pour pouvoir finaliser
une date et distribuer tout ça mais on
donnera un lieu on donnera une heure ce
sera bien précis et ce sera bien dit
mais on fera sur un système de
participation solidaire les gens
pourront ou pas donné voilà alors il
nous reste 30 secondes un petit mot
peut-être pour terminer sur
l'association poèmes qui a d'autres
actions avec un volet un gros volet
solidarité pour cette association
oui alors l'association un poème elle se
divise en un pôle solidaire donc avec
aussi bien de la saulaie de solidarité
locale qu'internationale
donc il ya aussi le pôle santé publique
avec notamment l'hôpital des nounours
que vous aimez bien relayée il ya aussi
le hall écologie donc ça c'est nouveau
de cette année et via le pôle écologie
on a voulu se battre avec ce projet pour
contre la précarité menstruel il ya
aussi des voyages
humanitaire solidaire qui seront
organisées dans le monde entier et voilà
je rappelle que poèmes enfin je précise
parce que je n'ai pas dit que paris
poèmes ça veut dire paris-ouest
étudiants en médecine on retrouve toutes
les informations sur cette association
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci à vous trois à charlotte baptiste
et manon bravo pour ce projet apporté au
sein de l'association poèmes et
direction versailles à présent le
domaine de madame elisabeth accueillait
vendredi dernier un forum économique qui
s'adressait la diaspora africaine une
première édition qui a réuni 350
personnes les détails avec aurélie rose
et manon varaldo comment peut-on
entreprendre en afrique une question
soulevée lors du premier forum
économique afrique français cartier à
versailles une manifestation organisée
par l'association envol objectif mieux
comprendre les écosystèmes de ces deux
entités complémentaires en france on a
deux savoir-faire on à la technologie en
afrique on a la connaissance du marché
on a la connaissance des vrais besoins
et les deux réunis permettent de faire
un bon mélange pour henry pour une
réussite entrepreneuriale l'afrique
c'est là où il ya le potentiel à
l'avenir et donc pour les sénégalais nos
enfants qui sont ici on leur donne
l'occasion de venus participer à
l'émergence par exemple du sénégal
politique investisseurs ou encore chefs
d'entreprise ils étaient au total 350
réunis au domaine de madame elisabeth le
but
principal est d'aider les pays de
l'afrique francophone a structuré
l'investissement individuel et privés
sur les sociétés innovantes autre but
permettre aux français notamment aux
yvelinois d'entreprendre en afrique de
manière structurée par le biais divine
coopération internationale et
développement le département soutient
également des initiatives en faveur de
l'afrique
les hybrides sont un département qui
accueille une importante diaspora
africaine et qui a noué des relations
très suivies très importante avec ce
continent africain justement dans cette
volonté en s'appuyant sur les diasporas
yvelinoise de participer au
développement d'un continent qui en a
bien besoin
cette première édition va également
permettre la mise en place d'une
plateforme d'accompagnement des
entreprises
c'est un indice positif de l'anah
l'agencé nationale de l'habitat le
programme habiter mieux depuis 2011 le
département des yvelines s'est saisie de
cette mesure pour l'amplifier à son
territoire en 2017 3400 événement
bénéficier d'une aide pour de la
rénovation énergétique c'est le cas d'un
foyer à houdan reportage de nicolas
landry c'est l'isolation du pignon entre
le garage et le couloir de la maison
avec son mari anne claire le bas via
houdan depuis 21 ans
trois hivers après leur rénovation
énergétique il économise environ 600
euros par an sur leur facture de
consommation d'énergie la maison date de
donc elle est assez âgée en avait
une grande déperdition de chaleur et
elles étaient chauffés entièrement à
l'électricité radiateur électrique qui
est aussi assez âgées penser à
l'environnement et puis on voulait aussi
faire des économies au niveau de la
facture d'électricité après l'achat de
ce poêles à granules ils ont appris
l'existence de l'accompagnement sur ce
type de travaux ils ont constitué un
dossier auprès de l'anah résultats sur
les 25000 800 euros de travaux
ils ont bénéficié de 3000 euros du
département et de 12000 euros de l'état
l'isolation des combles donc
l'entreprise a soufflé de la laine de
coton habiter mieux c'est le programme
dont a bénéficié anne-claire le bas
plusieurs critères à remplir être
propriétaire d'un logement construit il
ya plus de 15 ans une aide attribuée
sous conditions de ressources
on fait une double proposition aux
yvelinois à la fois une aide financière
qui vient compléter déjà les aides de
l'anah
il faut quand même savoir que cumuler
aide de l'anah et les aides du
département des yvelines on peut aller
jusqu'à 75 % du montant des travaux
financés par le programme habiter mieux
une deuxième proposition que fait le
département des yvelines aux yvelinois
c'est un accompagnement qui est à la
fois gratuit et neutre d'experts dans la
en la matière en matière de rénovation
énergétique deux opérateurs solia est
cité maîtrise ont missionné par le
département
objectif pour les yvelines accompagné
6000 ménages d'ici à 2023
au chapitre culturel ouverture du 9e
festival des images vagabonde elle avait
lieu vendredi dernier au ciné cette à
elancourt conférence sur l'histoire des
femmes dans le cinéma une projection du
film mignonne de maimouna doucouré est
l'événement organisé par l'association
contrechamp jusqu'au 29 mars propose un
parcours cinéma au travers d'une
thématique celle des femmes rebelles
cette année a été retenu plusieurs
animations sont programmées
écoutez
dans le programme du festival c'est
assez varié il ya des projections de
films de long métrage des courts
métrages des films pour le jeune public
ainsi que des conférences des ateliers
pratiques et une compétition de courts
métrages qui clôturera le festival à fin
mars une soirée de clôture qui se
tiendra le 28 mars à verneuil-sur-seine
retrouvez le programme complet de ce
festival sur le site qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran dans un instant sur tv
60,18 vous avez rendez vous avec le 7-8
sport lançant des résultats des
événements à suivre aussi prochainement
dans les yvelines et vous le verrez des
rencontres qui se sont bien tenues ce
week-end malgré le froid polaire comme
en rugby entre le rc 78 et le lin le
cetud sport c'est dans quelques minutes
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée à tous
sur tv 78
[Musique]